let's talk about so we we i think we we
got to the point on that one but what
happens then when you take a confusing
situation where you've got people who
want to do and you add in
derelict leadership right check out this
story check out the story all right
you're going to love this
from fox news white house abruptly cuts
feed of biden mid-sentence as he asks
question at wildfire's briefing biden's
white house has history of preventing
public from hearing him on the cuff it's
not the first time that after a
presentation or whatever people start
asking questions and the feed just
abruptly shuts off no it's happened
numerous times i mean one time he just
he he actually made the decision to turn
around and walk upstairs yes
he does it all the time it was after he
was talking about the the storm and they
were like what about afghanistan goes
nah we're not doing that he just walked
out i mean say what you want to about
trump i mean i i'm one of these people
that enjoyed trump's policies for the
most part there are some things i didn't
like about it but
the
sometimes he just went a little it's not
even that he went too far i understand
why he's talking about he's dead yeah
but it's
at some point you have to be like all
right cool man
i'm just gonna get the message out there
and then keep doing this good work cause
you know what nobody's talking about
right now it is the historic low
historically low unemployment and for
black people in the country
during trump you mean during trump yeah
nobody's talking right now no of course
not no nobody's talking about how uh the
five major peace deals between middle
eastern countries and and israel for the
first time in history right nobody's
talking about any of that stuff all
they're talking about is how he said xyz
about the election and how he's behaved
since then yep i feel like if you're
that right about stuff and it's
the results of his foreign domestic
economic policies were pretty good if
you're that right about stuff in
principle
i think you have some responsibility to
behave a certain way to continue getting
it done but i do understand that he was
under i people like to to do these
what-about-isms and talk about who gets
more heat than whom i've never seen
anybody get trashed more or more
regularly than donald trump never that
in the history of american media data
proves it yeah i've never seen it i mean
it's it's wild the data will do it the
data tracking negative negative press
for trump it was like ninety percent of
stories were negative and it was like
two to three times as many stories than
any other why is that was he a real
threat to the power structure oh yeah
dude of course
he he was look you had you had bernie
sanders and donald trump the insurgent
candidates and trump broke through i
don't know if any president can can
threaten the establishment anymore like
kennedy went down man he said i'm going
to bust up the cia and then he died
shortly after well i mean he always done
it since
kennedy
my understanding is that the ci clipped
him because of the bay of pigs because
he left he refused back there yeah oh
what's the story there the story well
you should have uh i know your fans
probably don't like him but you have
evan from black rifle come on he worked
for the agency for a while his theory is
that george h.w bush clipped kennedy
because he was one of the leaders of
that operation bay of pigs yeah yeah the
belief is that he was a knock a
non-official cover guy or like a you
know an operator and
the reason people believe that is
because he went from a congressman to
the deputy director operations which is
the most important job at the agency
like anything that happens there goes
through that office you know you know
the challenges with all that stuff
though is
how many assumptions you have to make
yeah
those aside i used to think that i could
get to the position of president and
then fix it i'll get in there i'll get
all the information i'll finally fix it
all so that we don't have to worry about
this anymore but now i'm it's just it's
such a web that you get in there as this
piece the king piece the king's the
terrible piece in chess i mean it
doesn't it's not you can't do it it's
you got to guard it because it's pretty
dead it's it's the worst piece we'll
know the pawn is the worst piece
technically well it's arguable pawns can
transform but the king's pretty terrible
it just sits there in hiding and wait
look to be honest i mean the president
the king can move one space in every
direction it's not bad okay nobody but a
little a little off topic the president
doesn't have as much power as we may
think there is the queen who's the queen
in our society right now i don't know
trump trump proved it trump tried to do
so much and he was blocked he should
have fired way more people but it's not
i don't need to get into trump right the
problem we have right now is that people
hated the guy so much because the media
had him so much because the
establishment hated him so much that now
we we are we are at lack thereof when it
comes to president when it comes to
leadership right joe biden is here's the
way i describe it donald trump was
anti-elected the enthusiasm for joe
biden was in the gutter and all the
trump's reporters saying that was
evidence that trump's going to win it's
going to be a landslide and trump's
enthusiasm was through the roof yeah but
enthusiasm against trump was through the
roof rivaling enthusiasm for him and so
people just voted for a jabbering
unwell man senile
vascular dementia let's be real right
vascular dementia and he and he would
call a lid call lid call lid and now
they won't even let him speak to the he
tries to answer questions and he goes i
know i'm gonna get in trouble if i do
this remember when he was doing he was
calling on the press and then one of the
journalists i think was from pbs asked a
question and he goes i thought the
question was supposed to uh anyway
like he knew in advance what he was
going to be asking and sometimes he's
like i'm not supposed to call on you but
what do you have to say yeah right like
you could tell us like the old joe biden
that's still rattling around there
somewhere that likes a good scrap you
know what it means just like all right
come on because that's again uh say what
you want about trump but he would stand
up there and and talk trash back and
forth with the media all day if they
would like yeah with jim acosta he would
just sit there and that would be the
presidency it would be four years of him
versus jim acosta what kind of uppers do
you think they got joe biden on so that
he can do these these these events be
it's got to be like b12 and adderall
right he's gotten mad
mainlining that stuff
into his body
there's no way he's
he he goes from this uh like hunched
over
guy that looks like he should be in an
old rickety
fdr era wheelchair with a with a shawl
in his lap that's a nice to a guy who's
like alert and bright but he's a little
too alert and he's giddy about being
he's got like what i mean they've been
mainline and modafinil and then like his
doctor's like he's talking to kamala we
can't keep pushing him like this his
blood is twenty percent modafinil i saw
a good uh i saw it good it's only
keeping him away for three hours at this
point
i saw a good meme today it was uh like
colin you have to stop answering the
phone did he die yet no jeez
it's a little
it's a little dark it's very disturbing
that we have this this this guy in
charge of the military right now
surrendering i'm far less concerned
about him being in charge of the
military as i am uh millie and lloyd
austin really these guys are
human garbage both of them why is that
but here's here's why let's go back to
this uh you you mentioned bagram earlier
a a private the lowest rank in the u.s
military in the 82nd airborne which is
who deployed over there
along with the marine corps
would know that what they did
strategically makes no sense
right removing your so the the thing
that is unique about the united states
military uh aside we have a great navy
we have nuclear capabilities we have
very well trained operators and soldiers
and marines and such but our air
superiority is where we really dominate
it doesn't matter who attacks us even
china at their advanced level right now
could not compete with us in air
superiority we remove our number one
piece we removed our queen off the board
and bagram
and
then what we had to redeploy i mean the
people that from the 82nd that went
there they're they're part of what's
called the drf1 the division ready force
they're on they're on standby to deploy
at any time within 18 hours and
that's not a game plan that's that's the
backup that's that's the break case of
emergency situation you don't do that so
when they went there and then they just
sat inside of the base waiting for
something to happen also not what you do
the 82nd airborne goes in and secures
the airfield and then typically uh
rangers
and sometimes marines maybe
rangers go
push out
crete standoff and then something like
jsoc will conduct operations in the area
right that's how that works and i know
millie knows this because he was in
panama where we did exactly that
right in 1989 like he knows all this
stuff so the fact that
these plans that biden had and this is
why by the way excuse me
this is why the armed services committee
has now requested or demanded rather
that lloyd austin give them his plan
right for the afghan extraction like
what the hell was this yeah this doesn't
make any sense yeah have you ever seen
congress demand the plan for a military
commander before because it didn't make
sense no not my lifetime right so
the question is why now we're seeing it
dakota maya and i were talking about
this
on our show and people
we said in the mainstream media a couple
places and people were like no that's
not happening and and and one
uh lady in particular tried to go after
us about it the pres our our idea was
this
uh and it's not an idea it's stuff we
heard from people but the idea is that
the reason that biden was so sure when
he said we're gonna get all our people
out the reason that he
had this stupid plan in the first place
the reason that he gave up a list of
american citizens to the taliban is
exactly what you saw yesterday so we
predicted that this past weekend going
into this week you would see airlifts of
u.s citizens coming out of afghanistan
and you would see pallets of cash going
in
so
saturday and sunday two planes full of
american citizens leave today it's
announced 64 million our billion dollars
is going back to the to afghanistan are
we going to pretend like that's not the
taliban like we did just give them 64
billion more dollars on top of the 88
this was this was always assumed to be
the out the outcome with uh with the
current leadership course lack thereof
when it comes to but the problem for me
is
i get all the politics and stuff like
that but how did that military plan
go all the way up the chain of command
and then all the way back down
to the people who executed the plan
without anybody ever seeing anything
it's a million it's 64 million i just
think 4 million sorry how did it go up
and down the chain without that's a good
question it's it's it's internal rot you
know look man that we had that professor
earlier the story came out where they
she compared she had 911 with an attack
on hetero patriarchal you know
capitalism or whatever yeah yeah
syracuse professor you've got
absolutely
institutional decay and we talk about
how the left dominates institutions but
i'm sorry what i really see happening is
just
there's there's interested groups
knocking down the united states period
think about it this way
there are people right now cheering for
joe biden's illegal
mandate that bypasses the legislative
branch he's already attempted to bypass
the legislative and the judicial with
his eviction moratorium and you have
people cheering for it that's basically
like the u.s system of governance has
been uh has been corrupted and is
breaking apart and they're celebrating
do you think it's happening i mean the
only way this could be more perfect is
if instead of biden it was joe lieberman
right because he looked like emperor
palpatine do you remember that guy does
everyone remember
from president yeah he was from
connecticut i think 2008 what did he run
i believe it was 2 000 or 2004. he was
in the primary i remember that guy yeah
he looked like palpatine but this is
this is that's what's happening here
it's very bizarre and i guess it always
kind of happens that way where
uh uh
i mean it's the only time that that
authoritarian movements are ever
actually effective is when you convince
the population that it's for their own
good first right and it is they accept
it but i think what we're seeing now is
that people don't care about what is
right what is wrong they just want to
feel good and so they want to do
whatever the tribe tells them to do
right and so that's why you have social
currency yeah thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you